laurent gibio bonjour oui bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on le
disait manifestation à guyancourt sur le
site renault
quelles sont les raisons qui vous
poussent aujourd'hui à vous mobiliser
les raisons sont de plusieurs ordres
la première celle qui est le catalyseur
de l'action des différentes actions qui
ont été menées depuis deux mois
maintenant c'est l'application chez
renault de l'article 12 24 qui
souhaitent qui veut que des salles des
salariés soit le je vais pas peur
d'employer les mots soient vendus en
même temps que leurs activités à des
boîtes de sous-traitance avec tout les
risques que ça comporte comme pour leur
avenir
quels types de risques par exemple comme
précédemment dans ce genre d'opération
il n'y a pas de garantie de pérennité de
la de l'activité on sous traite une
activité entre l'occurrence celle de d
l'entretien des bancs des moteurs c'est
un appel d'offres qui est fait par
renault auprès d'une boîte de sous
traitance
ces appels d'offres pour une durée de
trois ans au bout de trois ans il ya une
autre entreprise arrive avec un meilleur
prix ce sera elle qui sera choisi et
donc les salariés qui ont été vendues
avec l'activité se retrouveront de fait
en chômage ou dans le pire des cas
voilà c'est ça c'est ça je dirais c'est
la face visible de l'iceberg
c'est ce qui cristallise aujourd'hui les
différentes actions sur les sites
d'ingénierie en île de france mais aussi
en province
maintenant ça relève aussi de grands
dessous d'eux
ça montre aussi qu'on a aussi des grands
soucis sur sur le l'aspect social en
algérie
c'est à dire se sont sont concernés sont
des ingénieurs fille d'amendé chef
d'equipe qui vont se mobiliser
aujourd'hui tout le monde on a des
techniciens on a des ingénieurs des
cadres tout le monde et tout le monde
est concerné aujourd'hui par parle
comment par les suppressions d'emplois
qui sont en cours chez renault les
suppressions de postes qui sont en cours
chez renault depuis depuis bientôt un an
maintenant ce qui esquisse ce qui est
d'ailleurs plutôt rare de devoir
également des cols blancs se mobiliser
quel est le dialogue aujourd'hui avec la
direction de renault
le dialogue c'est un peu comme vous avez
montré jouer les images de la fondation
frotter les images des camarades de mbr
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de dialogue
c'est un langage de sourds nous on a
apporté
fabien roussel l'a dit les personnes
l'ont dit on apporte un comment un
projet industriel
on apporte des propositions autre que la
suppression de postes c'est une fin de
non recevoir
aucun dialogue aucun dialogue aucune
négociation en cours à 7 heures avec la
direction de renault donc alors les
dialogues qui on n'a pas les
négociations y aurait beaucoup c'est
aussi paradoxal que cela puisse paraître
on parle énormément du dialogue social
dans les entreprises et particulièrement
chez renault ça tient très à coeur à
tout le monde sauf que le dialogue il
faut une deux aujourd'hui on a affaire à
un monologue la direction arrive avec
ses idées elle nous dit 2500
suppressions de postes dans l'ingénierie
et les suivait les fonctions support ici
fin 2021
c'est à prendre ou à laisser que vous
soyez d'accord ou pas d'accord de toute
façon on fera alors on va faire en bas
négocier je dirais la déprime de départ
et puis ça va s'arrêter là jamais au
grand jamais on a essayé de trouver
d'autres pistes pour préserver l'emploi
c'est malheureusement selon ce qu'ont
subies depuis depuis la fin des années
80 dans les usines qui avec bourg
pendant vingt ans on a vidé les usines
des salariés renault pour les remplacer
par des parts de la précarité
un terrible par exemple et puis une fois
qu'on est arrivé à vider complètement
les usines et bien maintenant s'attaque
aux on s'attaque depuis une petite
dizaine d'années et plus
particulièrement maintenant depuis
depuis un an et demi ce qui reste c'est
à dire l'algérie est là bas là il n'ya
plus d'histoire de col bleu puis des
scores de col blanc
c'est tout le monde dit tout le monde y
passe on a du coup on imagine une
atmosphère assez lourde ces derniers
temps dans les couloirs de de chez
renault des journées de travail
difficiles avec une honorable mois
s'avère compliqué et oui parce qu'en
plus de ça s'ajoutent les problèmes des
crises des composants qui nous ont
amenés à faire de l'activité partielle
longue durée donc on est au chômage on
nous a mis au chômage d'office tous les
vendredis jusqu'à mi jusqu'à mi août
on nous prend des heures des jours de
congé on se voit là et malgré ça elle et
c'est là tout le paradoxe de l'histoire
c'est que on a énormément de travail sur
tous les sites d'ingénierie
on est en train de préparer l'avenir de
renault donc une bonne chère défense
vendredi
non non non j'ai pas dit ça j'ai pas dit
ça j'ai pas dit qu'il y avait une bonne
santé de financière de renault
ça ce serait dire ça ça serait plutôt un
mensonge
non ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que nous
le travail qu'on fait aujourd'hui on a
dégénéré moi je suis dessinateur
industriel avant d'être délégué syndical
donc je suis dis moi ce que je dessine
je dessine pas les véhicules qui vont
sortir qui vont sortir à la fin à la fin
du mois c'est ce qu'ils vont sortir dans
qui vont sortir d'ici deux ans
oncle à venir mais ça ça nous on est
bien obligé de le mettre en place
c'est à dire effectivement aujourd'hui
la situation financière de renault et
par brillante sapho ça faut être
accueillis side mais clairement notre
travail conserve que l'on fait
aujourd'hui que l'on produit aujourd'hui
servira à sortir de l'ornière mais pas
un pas dans un avenir court métrage à
moyen terme
c'est ça c'est ça tout le paradoxe
aujourd'hui on est punis on est puis à
porte parce qu'il ya eu des choix qui
ont été faits les choix stratégiques qui
ont été faits par part d'autre part les
directeur d'avant on est puni
aujourd'hui mais on hypothèque
aujourd'hui de punition il peut être
l'avenir d'ordre toutes les luttes ou
l'aider tout ce qu'on va pouvoir sortir
comme nouveau véhicule que ce soit en
véhicules utilitaires ou en véhicules
particuliers
c'est aujourd'hui que ça se passe c'est
pas plus tard pourquoi peut-être pour
conclure on 5 renault bénéficie d'aidés
prêts garantis par l'état
pourtant les suppressions de postes à se
poursuivaient ce que vous en a appelé à
l'état également aujourd'hui oui oui
sachant que l'état est le principal
actionnaire de renault c'est ça q
complètement dingue
celle que l'on des dons on a meta donc
qui sont l'état pèse 15 points 1 % dans
l'accident le poids de renault et
aujourd'hui donc il donne en plus et
redone
ils prennent de l'argent pour pouvoir ça
pour pouvoir sortir ono de l'ornière
mais à côté de ça il faut qu'on y entend
que propriétaire de l'entreprise dit
fait rien pour essayer de sauvegarder
l'emploi
c'est une paille donc nous au même titre
que toutes les autres actions que vous
avez présenté avance et on demande que
juste que que l'argent public
notre argent celles qui servent et qui
devraient après qui devrait servir aux
écoles à la santé voilà tout cet argent
qu'ils devraient faire tourner là
qui devait faire tourner la nation soit
employé pour préserver tout faire pour
préserver l'emploi et pas seulement pour
licencier merci merci à vous le rend
gibelot d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rd france je le rappelle
vous êtes délégué syndical cgt renault